MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to "DataVis DevTalk."
I'm your host, Minhaz Kazi.
Today's guest is Marc Soares.
Marc is the manager of analytic
solutions at ClickInsight.
Marc is also a constant
advocate for effective data
visualization and storytelling.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Marc, welcome to the show.
MARC SOARES: Thanks, Minhaz.
It's good to be here.
MINHAZ KAZI: So tell the
audience a little bit
about yourself.
What is your role
at ClickInsight?
MARC SOARES: I am the manager
of our analytics solutions team
at ClickInsight.
We are a digital
analytics consultancy.
We are also a Google
Marketing platform partner.
And my team is
responsible for everything
from implementing
analytics on a website,
setting up to
Google Tag Manager,
creating reports and
dashboards, often
with Google Data Studio, all
the way to conducting analysis
and providing insights and
recommendations to our clients.
So you could say we do the full
stack of digital analytics.
MINHAZ KAZI: So you do
a lot of visualizations
with Data Studio.
How do you get started with it?
MARC SOARES: I was
interested in Data Studio
from the very beginning.
I started using it about as
early as it was available.
And I think there were
a couple key benefits
that I saw from very early on
that attracted me to the tool.
One was the native integration
with Google Analytics.
The other main benefit was
the ease of sharing reports.
You can share a
link, and the viewer
can have access to
that report, even
without logging
in or downloading
another application.
And so for those two
reasons, I was really
attracted to Data Studio
in the first place.
And what's kept me
interested is all the updates
and enhancements that
have been rolled out
over time to really make it
a more powerful reporting
product.
MINHAZ KAZI: So you started
with Google Analytics data,
and you've been creating
reports that you
share with your key
members and your clients.
But recently, you've been using
Data Studio for other purposes
as well.
For example, you make
almost weekly contributions
to the Makeover Monday contest.
So how do you get started
with that, the whole practice
of taking this new
data set every week
and then creating visualizations
from that data set?
MARC SOARES: Makeover Monday
is a community project
where, every week,
there's a new data set,
and visual posted,
with the idea being
that participants will
take that same data set
and create an improved
version of the chart.
I started participating
in Makeover Monday
even before I started
using Google Data Studio.
And it was for the reason of
giving myself an opportunity
to practice and improve my
data visualization skills.
And by having that different
chart, different topic,
different type of
data set every week,
it provides a great opportunity
to practice and learn
new skills.
And with Data Studio, by forcing
yourself to be in the tool
regularly, I can keep
my skills up to date
and learn some of
the new features
and enhancements in the tool.
MINHAZ KAZI: One of
your visualizations
were also included in
the Makeover Monday book.
What is your process for
creating these visualizations?
How do you start
with a data set?
What is your process for
picking chart types, or forms
and colors?
And what would be the
size of everything?
Where do you start, how do
you go through the process,
and how do you publish?
MARC SOARES: I think
I have established
a pretty consistent
process over the time
that I've been doing
Makeover Monday.
It always starts with the data.
The data set's usually provided
in a spreadsheet or CSV format.
When I'm using Data Studio,
the first thing I'm going to do
is create a data source,
so that I have access
to those fields in Data Studio.
But before I jump into
creating any charts or visuals,
I like to get to know
the data set a bit more.
I take a look at what
fields are available,
what dimensions and metrics
are in the data set.
And that often requires reading
some background material
on where that data comes from.
Often, it's part
of a larger report,
or it was published
as part of an article,
or there's some more
description about that data set.
I think that's always
important to understand
the data before
you start using it,
to make sure that
whatever interpretations
you're going to make
or however you're
going to tell the story--
that it's consistent with what
the data actually represents.
Once I get to know
the data, I can
go into creating some
charts in Data Studio.
I try to choose the
most appropriate chart
for the message that I
would like to communicate
or the story that
I want to tell.
Depending on whether I'm
trying to show all the data
or focus on a
particular aspect of it,
I may make different
decisions about which
charts are most appropriate.
That often involves some
experimentation in the tool.
But once I've decided on what
the most appropriate way is
to visualize the
data, I can then
add to it with
more visual aspects
of colors and fonts and
layout to really make
a more polished final product.
But I think that,
overall, is the process
that I follow every week
with Makeover Monday.
MINHAZ KAZI: It is
interesting that when
you're talking
into visualization,
it's not just the chart types.
You also have the
data, so you have
to have some domain
knowledge about the data.
Then there's the
storytelling part--
what story am I going to
tell with this whole data?
And then building the vis
based on those two principles.
Your approach to
data visualization
seems to be very unique.
You're using the common
chart types, like bar charts
and scatter plots,
and you're operating
within the same techniques
and limitations,
but you're coming up with
something very unique.
What inspires you?
How do you get inspiration
for these unique approaches
to data visualization?
MARC SOARES: Yeah, I
think I draw inspiration
from a lot of different sources.
With many of the Makeover
Monday visualizations
that I've created, I do try to
push the boundaries of what's
possible with the tool in
particular, with Data Studio,
and try to show something
that perhaps people
haven't seen before
or they didn't think
was possible with the tool.
But at the same
time, I always try
to respect the
data and the story
that I'm trying to
tell, and make sure
that the message is clear
and that the visual doesn't
get in the way of them.
And in that context I
have drawn inspiration
from people like Edward
Tufte and Stephen Few, who
have written a lot about the
field of data visualization,
and the principles of
communicating clearly
with information.
I also draw inspiration
from others that contribute
to the visualization community.
There are a lot of creative
and talented people
that create and share
data visualizations,
and I think I try and pull
bits and pieces from everything
that I see and apply
that in my own work.
MINHAZ KAZI: Talking
about community,
you have built a number of
community visualizations
and community connectors
for Data Studio.
This community is still
young and growing.
What do you think about
the developer community
and the prospects
that a new developer
has in building solutions
with Data Studio?
MARC SOARES: I've
done a bunch of work
with the community connectors
and visualizations,
creating those custom
components for Data Studio.
One thing I should
clarify is that I don't
consider myself a developer.
I can certainly code, and I'm
comfortable with JavaScript
and HTML and CSS, but I'm
not a full-time developer,
nor have I ever been
a full-time developer.
But I think that speaks to
the ease with which the custom
components for Data
Studio can be created.
It doesn't require
an expert developer
to be able to connect
to data sources
or create custom
visualizations for Data Studio.
You do need a bit of programming
experience and knowledge,
but I think what's more
important is to understand
the structure of the
data, how it would be
used in a report or dashboard.
And putting that knowledge
together, I think,
gives anyone a
really good ability
to create these
custom components.
Right now the data vis
community around Data Studio
is still growing.
But I think, because of the
framework that's in place,
it provides a great
opportunity for more developers
to get involved and build
out more custom components.
MINHAZ KAZI: What would
be your favorite tip
that you would give to our
audience with Data Studio?
MARC SOARES: That's
a good question.
At least one of my
favorite tips is something
that I do in my Makeover Monday
visualizations very frequently.
It's a rather simple thing,
but I hide the page boundary.
What it does is creates a
very clean and crisp look
to your visualization.
The background fills the screen.
And if you go into
full-screen mode,
then you really have a true
full-screen experience.
So it's something
very simple, but I
think it has a great impact
on the final visualization.
MINHAZ KAZI: When would
you use a pie chart?
[LAUGHTER]
MARC SOARES: I think
I may only use a pie
chart to explain to you why
you shouldn't use pie charts.
They're certainly not
my favorite chart type,
and there are many
reasons why other chart
types are most often better.
MINHAZ KAZI: All, right folks.
That's the end of our show.
Thanks again to
Marc for being here.
If you want to see more
content on Data Studio,
make sure that you subscribe
to the GCP channel.
And you can always visit
our developers' site
at developers.google.com.
Until the next time, keep
making more visualizations.
[MUSIC PLAYING]